[Music]
what's up guys welcome to winners on a
Wednesday where we interview success
stories success students every single
week and this week I'm privileged to
bring Ben and Abby on to the show they
came to the crash course their deal
packaging that the rent to serviced
accommodation
they've refurbished refinanced a
property and they're absolutely killing
it and they've both quit their jobs are
now financially free so Ben and Abby
welcome to the show this has been a long
time coming
you've been wonderful winners Wednesday
for so long but you've you've been
holding off until you've got a really
good story so why don't you guys give me
a little bit of background as into
because I did a post on Facebook and
said what do people want to see on
winners Wednesday and they said one of
these stories we want to see things that
go wrong I know you've had things go
wrong and we want and we want some real
facts and figures and stuff so why don't
you guys start off by giving it to their
background to your story and for me
personally I always wanted to have like
a normal life because when I was 9 I got
diagnosed with a brain tumor so I've had
brain surgery twice and had hospital
treatments and I had a great childhood
but I always have this going on so I
just kind of wanted a normal life or
it's a firehouse settle down get married
and have 2.5 children and that was like
my life plan yeah met Ben thought this
is on track we're doing great
and then I had everything we'd bought a
nice house we'd settle down we were
going to get married and I've got
depression so everything was perfect
around me but I do feel happy and I
don't it just came off no I don't even
know why it happened but the worst like
nine months of my life couldn't work for
a few months as well so when we got
through all of that benefit were a
smallish crash boss and we're talking
about this Samuel guy maybe read a book
and I was like yeah
I just wanna get married and have babies
and anyway finally got me to go to a bar
and at this point what you were
depressed and you guys got together you
wanted to get into property and stuff
but RB was feeling really oh this is
ridiculous
what was he been that I mean what was it
that made you want to come to the crash
course and get into property it was just
you you see I've always been interested
in property and he sent me $2 by me for
every finance that was before you and
you off your strategy but it's just
obvious I've always been clear we got
we've like the construction standard of
things on it duquan trains and stuff
like this
we knew we have equity in the house from
doing it up and I didn't know what to do
with it
so you were thinking you could refinance
the house and do something with it how
would you have felt about that at the
time just because everyone just sort of
says hi I have equity in my house and
nothing my dad said to me one of these
tips that really wasn't a good tip at
all
it's a pity mom but you say pay mortgage
off as fast as you can yeah yeah so
obviously I was there most people find
jeffing through YouTube and I was
searching and yep hard to be there's all
these people battle you evolve master
thinking that was complicated and you
cannot do well yeah property's not that
difficult really is it it's quite simple
so you came to the crash course and then
what happened it changed our lives but
went into it I've got a board as I've
read your book and looked at YouTube and
saw things it sounded good but I thought
what will do it it's like a side project
you know but maybe something we can do
in the future
yeah then we came out of the first day
like
my god we've got to quit our jobs we've
got to make a business we've got to do
all these things and take action on
everything sound of the Academy
literally this is it new path what
wedding
what kids this was it yeah change
completely that's crazy that you came
and and and Abbey you guys were working
full-time at the time and I remember
when we met at the crash course and we
were speaking and you I remember you
saying happy you went I just hate my job
this is what we had to say and at that
time just a be even lighter no sort of
busy event it was a big big thing
because I mean I'd say the depression it
was more anxiety yeah
and just from you like an inspiration
from years like saying get out of your
comfort zone play a little 10 it's a big
deal though it's a massive deal and
obviously you you know you desired
something something great to happen in
your life but it's incredible and and
that's why we run these programs that's
why we run the crash course so ok so you
came to the crash course and you
realized that you wanted to get into
property what were you doing what jobs
were you both doing
so I mean nerves which I absolutely love
being a nurse but the job at ended up in
was kind of a nitrifying more admin
office bit yeah everything I really
didn't like it
yeah the money was was great but it was
not a proper nurse yeah I like doing
that but now that I can be financially
free and I'd like to go back into proper
nursing okay interesting because you can
write a choice I mean when you join the
Academy you were you're working as an
doing admin stuff that what were you
doing I was I was working for a company
better service and like it was I liked
the job because it wasn't like
traditional 60 violins it was found yeah
yeah but I'm gonna have a conversation
with you guys
it must have only been about four or
five months ago and you were like okay
now we're in property we're in the brand
the Academy we've done the crash course
and I would be saying once you've got a
few deals who should quit their job
first remember that yeah master Jewish
my man away from so relaxing where you
could literally day off yeah it was like
me figure 2 weeks nice and you got are
yours like Maury three balls so you both
for your student first and since then
you've both quit your jobs how did that
happen how did you end up quitting your
jobs I mean what was your strategy you
didn't have a big pot of money you had a
little bit that quitting your house tell
us tell us what happened tells the story
well though I'm always really careful
well I'm always really careful because
when people say to me should I quit my
job I don't want to say yeah quit your
job and then they quit it and then I'm
thinking geez now they're now they're on
the streets solenoids I've got to be
really careful because I don't want to
be responsible for that
but except talk about our conversation
- oh I was I think it was the day I
wouldn't let you quit your job - it was
the debt soon as for analysis cost yeah
and after that was 15 you can definitely
do this and then he says obviously
became a menace always what start
thinking we really can't fail in my head
and can't fail yeah but you just wanted
Samuel to say yes that's fine but I
wouldn't say well I I have to be stupid
here if you say no I say up we did see a
car recommend you do anything yeah we've
sold so many deals through Alice do at
that point so you said that and then you
change back I just read you know what
man just quit just quit just so it was
deal it was because I know on the
Academy he did some training with
Alastair and yeah it was it was Dale
packaging wasn't it that enabled you to
originally quit your job so talk to me
about that the inventor how did you go
from not knowing anything about property
to now knowing so much that people are
paying you to find them deals what does
that look like as you know I sort of
didn't know about probably any way of
being Posterous which I saw in the early
obviously know if it's a good boy and
I'm the involved it is I checked that
boy was specialized in yes as I can but
I didn't know I structural things aren't
done but the training you get especially
like Trevor Trevor has helped me out
massively would be looking for issues
the end I've commanded a book supplier
to read and yeah from going from not
want nothing to die is just a training
really
so you went all the training and what
did you learn on the training what are
the key skills that you learned that
enabled you to make money as a deal
packager
you've got to know what people looking
for what sells yeah obviously with the
20%
that's what people are looking for if
you get that so you've been basically
trying to find houses that are cheap
knocking them down on price getting a
really good deal that's gonna rent out
well presenting all the data presenting
you know have what the letting agents
are saying what whence you're gonna get
all that sort of stuff and then people
say you know what that's a great house
and I'll pay you to basically be
introduced to that is that right one
thing I can say I've been learning
however is when we when we bought our
house really was definitely evolved very
badly
yeah and it was like last night fire and
offerings
mine games that really wanted it
probably other still yeah and what what
we've learned through like the deal
packaging is not to be involved in buyer
just you put loads of offers in what do
you think it is backup you don't accept
it that's it yeah I've had one that I
offer the silly amount I think it was it
was on for like 120 well other price so
I thought I put an offering what would
work be the ROI himself and said no no I
think it must be like three months later
they got back to me and said we only for
nothing that many more offers would you
be interested
yeah and that's when a far far the sound
desperate
yes that's what that's my offer
I'll think of putting it 75 Wow it's
like 120 offered 75 now really I knew it
wasn't worth can't win it's because
asking price and market value or two
different things
new in the condition wasn't food we're
flying five yeah they are dead local to
me like ninety ninety-five and saying oh
please just yeah so you're desperate
right and all through a bit less that's
a nice I worked out the refit because
only put that much time to working at
the reefer to actually worked on the
reefer and because the damp issues and
it's sort of a few issues mmm
gone down so in fact we got never
accepted and that was one of the deals
we put yeah that's fantastic
so I mean if you've if you've got a
property and you've got on a grid voice
of 75 and it's worth 100 or more then
people are gonna pay you know several
thousand pounds for that do as long as
you can demonstrate that it really that
this is the true market value and this
is what I've got it for you know what
would you say to people that said that
you're taking advantage of the of the
sellers they're a desperate person in a
desperate situation and you're coming on
cutthroat you know offering a really do
you not think that's a little bit a bit
unethical yeah you know finding someone
to buy it for them yeah
by a mr. BAE the same situation yes
they're posted another vironment but
with feet like we're obviously people
trust us now to find these deals so
we've got and we'll get to that in a
minute as well as we it's bowing over
there because we just we can look at it
if he works for us he'll work for our
investors yes I see we're helping them
yelping the person sell you then finding
an investor that wants a good deal
you're bringing the two together and
you're charging a fee that's fantastic
how do you find the investor because I
know you guys that was your big problem
to begin with and we were helping you
with your person deals through I was
there as part of the Academy but now you
know I know you've been on some of the
training that we've probably the Academy
what have you learned that's enabled you
to get such a because you've got hominy
800 hot investors on your mailing list
ready to buy that's an incredible amount
of investors that you've built up over
the last few months how have you done
that I've didn't obviously a lot of
networking coming to events and speaking
to people telling everyone what would
you mean and putting our social media
will get a lot of people sending
messages to it as good as what we're
doing as if we do this sort of thing
that sort of they just feel you know
yeah yeah yeah even just being
associated with you it helps people most
massively trust you
yeah the part of the economy yours
you're automatically one step oh yeah
sure not wolf everybody else alone and
philosophical in knowledge yeah train
pit you serious people yes people know
that you're an Academy member obviously
and also other Academy members there
were some people on the academy that I
know now I'm happy to pay you to find
the deals just because they haven't got
that they've got a lot of money they've
got the knowledge but they'd rather you
find the deals because they have a lot
of time
style I said it difficult with the staff
is younger than your first deal so I
beyond the Academy helps us because
you're good with Excel is 4 so 3 yeah
really we have solve it we sourced it
and sold it for us yeah but you could
say I'm sorry let's get a bit more
credibility yeah and then when you
finally get some sales from yours
then people yeah I just recommendations
a lot of people do that on the academy
they'll we call it Co deal sourcing
where you'll find the deal but because
you haven't got any investors and you
might not be compliant or whatever to
begin with your first two or three
you'll pass through and another sorcerer
and then you'll work out some kind of
Commission split and that's what a lot
of academies of thus do to begin with in
their early days you're now selling your
own properties which is incredible now I
know you've done you've also had talked
to me about your refurb refinance deal
which was your own house how did that
pan out
wrecked and this fit the criteria and
you exactly which was we were going to
build which was gonna come down boy
there's just no question kind of cheap
artful and how much did you spend on it
okay so you took it so you bought it for
205 it's been 20 so altogether you put
down about two to five and then how much
did you be value out to six days nice
one
so you pulled out a large fifty five
thousand pounds which is
we're like that is honestly the house on
the for sale are not hasn't sold yet and
put its for sale on the same street 360
now I was a good man section yeah I put
100 care yeah that's incredible though
nice and and and you you didn't you
weren't really aware of this until what
they told the crash course yeah
knowledge is just exploded
yeah you just mark that stuff you learn
on crash course is just you just you
just wouldn't ever think you as possible
yeah why I say you I do it all you just
have to know how to do it oh yeah like
we are doing these options we would like
that one that 75k I've talked about yeah
I asked sensibly there's a to the vendor
I'll try to sell it for you
you know exhausting options but if I
can't sell it I'm merely on to offer you
something else I said that to I said
okay that's brilliant
well the thing is when you know all the
different strategies you know how to do
lease option agreement rent to rent
serviced accommodation HMOs below market
value by and we finance you've got all
strategies what happens is you become
you become this fountain and you can
have all these little strategies up your
sleeve and be a property problem solver
and stand in front of people who are
motivated to sell a say how can I help
which is I know you you've done you've
done you've got three went to rent deals
how much were you rent to make deals
roughly you're gonna be bringing in over
the on average at per month mm Oh mm a
month oh okay no two thousand a year
average because it's because they're
serviced accommodation so some months
will be amazing some of us obviously not
so great
so 24 grand a year approximately on your
rent to serviced accommodation which is
like sure white replaced and then with
the deal packaging how much how much
money are you making on average like say
have you met her last couple of months
doing deal packaging
and a half thousand pound of deals in
the last six weeks so Wow two thousand a
week yeah
and that's fantastic and I know you've
had with the deal packaging it wasn't
all smooth sailing at the first now you
guys are now professional you and that's
what you sell so many deals you're
you've got a really good reputation tell
us some of the struggles and problems
that you had in the early days oh we
sold quite a few deals in after six
weeks of being up and running as our own
business and they all they all fell
through that was like six deals in six
weeks that all fell through for various
reasons yeah a lot of it was just being
unlucky yeah I'll tell you one get a
block flats and was over the new
landlord said yeah it works easy
Gentiles for renters for shorts dear
this was a rental cycle yeah and the
agent said yeah it's fine so we then put
it out to uninvested stuff to do it off
it worked on me was we sold them deals
so we got their money in our account and
on a client account and then I had a
phone call from the agent they said she
says oh what we've it's definitely not
true she came back to me said actually
but I want it after observing I said I
was waiting for it right I might have
the least to read it myself without
taking their word for it so I said well
when's it commit I've sort of actually
got the money they can't and then she
said I did I just had it checked by a
solicitor and it doesn't and it doesn't
matter for shorts dead know so the deals
are void so I almost feel like that
gives you more credibility refunding
because so what do you need so presume
what did you do that in that instance we
ran our investors apologized obviously
it's but to the agents can of straighten
things out and then just gave them full
refund well we did ask for actually
offer one of the investors wanted to
replacement properties anyway I think
the thing is when you're deal wag urging
it's not about if there's a problem that
comes up it doesn't matter too much it's
about how you deal with that yeah
and the thing is you're on the academy
and every single problem that happened
in the early days I know there was a few
and you were really disappointed in the
early days I'm gonna be saying is this
normal and and we said well you know not
total it does happen it's happening a
lot but you know you refunded the
investors you looked after them or you
found them a replacement and because of
that they then bought again yeah people
watching this to know it's not smooth
sailing mmm
because I think naps and people you know
they'll get these setbacks and they'll
be like it doesn't work yeah we must we
have a lot of setbacks all evolved and
always carried on yeah just having you
come to you for advice gives us a price
in the other go and then doing a look at
your reputation and your list and like I
said if things go wrong we just just
refund it when I steal people's money or
nothing that's a big thing about sauces
it's the trust yeah so if they can trust
us
yeah and they know that if something
goes wrong which it can you even every
fund them or you're gonna ask them what
you wanted what you get you're gonna
sort it out
that's brilliant original thought we
were gonna buy something and there was a
mortgage issue and I remember saying to
you this is good
we knew this isn't going to be massively
easy the first problem we've gone so far
this is brilliant
yeah actually means we've got to our
first problem that way we can move on
and learn from it yeah and I've learned
a lot from from those days yeah and now
I don't seem to be happening so much now
though you seem to be on look ease on
your side at the moment with sales
oh yeah yeah go on tell us so we was
firing the deals book I just couldn't
work on where it's going on and we are
on the Academy dinner cuz you were
finding the best deals yeah the best
deals and you also had a you a growing
list of investors but when you would
email it out people would respond but
you just couldn't
get people's money in your bank about
get back to ya maybe even longer
Naaman after one investor talking off a
deal it's all about the closing of the
deal yeah it's not like that yeah you
need your clothes
yeah here's what you need to do and this
is what I taught you you need to find a
quick prequalify the investor rather
than the investor coming to you with a
million questions you send the deal
details out and then the investor comes
to you and you got a hold on let me just
a new prequalify there if the investor
fits the house fits then you just can't
ask them great
how would you like to pay it's a 2,000
pound finder's fee to secure your
property how would you like to poke that
I think I was quite skeptical about the
service the fee and things like feeling
like I didn't deserve that money yeah so
now believing in my own product you
taught me how it's a good service you
want to save you some one time and times
money yeah the Apple deals that makes me
feel more confident in putting European
and taking a deal as they are this one's
good sending out to investors like
Holland advantages I wanted to find that
deal so it was looking at that deal all
right yeah viewed it on our at our back
then offered menu like find a five hours
for that deal - Vicki she's not a matter
of five so I swap around too much per
hour too much power
well those you take into consideration
the profit is that beat and also they
mount the evening there's not only
amount of money that you've invested in
your education yes yes that's another
reason
use a saucer lack of knowledge and yeah
yeah now I feel confident that we have
to find a good service would want
something far so that helps I would you
say your self-worth is now gone yeah
because I didn't even know some of the
stuff you said on this like you you guys
I mean happy you're so confident you
know you're on you've just been on stage
at this event sharing your story and
stuff is absolutely fantastic would you
say that the property has changed your
life relapsed and I've always been next
week proper you know clip what yeah
girls and there are girls ever and I've
got girls I couldn't see where we're
going this augustness
almost didn't reach we've got ideas of
doing some projects like more
renovations yeah conveyance and you've
done really well you've got you've got a
lot of experience you're both left your
jobs your full time property you
financially free now because you brought
leads pretty much what's your strongest
reason why yeah holiday next month oh my
goodness and you can do that because you
just made twelve and a half thousand
pounds which is just fantastic
it's nice to treat a holiday in years
it's just nice to just last a treat to
treat your family when your parents
brought you up and you know made you who
you are it's nice to just give back and
treat them to a holiday and things like
that has the has the property being in
property together as you've brought you
guys closer together so you could go
weeks without probably see each other
yeah that's nice what's happening in
July that's so cool I'm so pleased for
you guys what would be yours best piece
of advice you would give to someone who
was just thinking about starting out
maybe similar to yourselves
no background in property maybe
struggling with depression or self-worth
or anything hate their jobs you hate it
everyone used to you go I hate my job
yeah what advice would you give to them
I would say doing what you are thinking
about is the best first step you know
starting to think about it like we were
just doing it and then like turning it's
one of these events that they're wrong
for free that was present it was huge
yeah this is good that you do it for
free as well because they just gives
them that chance to get the towing yeah
that's what we were doing I'm gonna
stiffen up so maybe you ever definitely
think about it my friends just bust last
week we went on the crash course with my
best man yeah
and he's his manners blur
yes his girlfriend a bit of a skeptic
yeah
his fiancee has changed - so she acts
just just like you say with a bring my
people brainwashed - like was it a good
job look - yeah anyway yeah so that
change people's minds and it's just like
things to reality what could be possible
yeah almost the crushed glass and
doesn't have the mind blown that it's
not for them yeah I agree and I mean
watching YouTube videos is dipping your
toe in going on the crash course is just
transformational and you guys have chose
to go on and continue your your journey
and you're on the Academy which is just
great and I'm so proud of you guys and
I'm really pleased to have you good
friends as well so thank you ever so
much for sharing your story and I can't
wait to see what's next for you guys
so fist pump you're awesome thank you so
much well guys if you enjoyed that win
as Wednesday
and you would like to be sat here with
me also as a success student then the
best thing best piece of advice as these
guys have said is get yourself booked on
a property investors crash course link
is below
it's on me on the house I look forward
to seeing you there my name is Samuel
Leeds thank you for watching winners on
a Wednesday every single week we
interview a success students for your
inspiration you can watch more right
here on the playlist as a whole playlist
of them so what you'll notice is every
single winner on a Wednesday always
starts with them coming to my two day
crash course so if you would like to be
a winner on a Wednesday literally come
on my crash course and who knows in
three months time you could be here in
my offices on this show as a winner on a
Wednesday so get yourself booked on the
crash course watch more have fun I'll
see you next week